[Musique]
LCP Assemblée Nationale en partenariat
avec MGEN mutuelle santé prévoyance
présente état de santé
[Musique]
ce tordre de douleur chaque mois au
moment des règles est-ce vraiment normal
c'est ce qu'on long en cru les parents
les médecins et les femmes elles-mêmes
j'étais tellement seule depuis 10 ans à
chercher des réponses à droite à gauche
avoir des généralistes à parler autour
de moi de mes douleurs et j'avais aucune
réponse mais aujourd'hui les patientes
se font entendre c'est grâce à elle que
la prise en charge et le diagnostic de
l'endométriose se sont améliorés ces
dernières années malgré tout il n'existe
toujours pas de traitement ciblés contre
cette maladie en cause la banalisation
des douleurs et un manque d'intérêt pour
la recherche sur la santé des femmes le
budget du net était de 1 milliard de
dollars pour le diabète et de 304
millions de dollars pour l'asthme et il
était seulement de 7 millions de dollars
pour l'endométriose alors comment mieux
prendre en charge la maladie comment les
patientes font-elles bouger les lignes
de la santé gynécologique endométriose
les femmes prennent la parole c'est le
thème de ce nouveau numéro d'état de
santé
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cet
état de santé sur LCP il a longtemps
semblé normal que les femmes se tordent
de douleur une fois par mois parce
qu'elles avaient leurs règles et bien le
regard de la société et de la médecine
aussi comment changer lentement mais
sûrement et on va parler avec vous
Isabella chanavaz bonjour Merci beaucoup
alors que vous êtes une des grandes
spécialistes de ce qu'on appelle
l'endométriose on est très heureux de
vous recevoir parce que en réalité on en
parle très peu de cette maladie dans les
études de médecine s'est enseigné depuis
quelques années seulement oui tout à
fait l'endométriose n'était pas au
programme des études de médecine et donc
on en parlait un petit peu à droite à
gauche on en parlait dans le chapitre
sur les douleurs dans le chapitre sur
les saignements mais il y avait pas un
chapitre consacré spécifiquement à
l'endométriose qui veut dire que tous
les professionnels de santé avaient
entendu parler de cette maladie mais ne
savait pas exactement ce que c'était et
c'est une des choses qui fait que il y a
un défaut de connaissances et donc un
défaut de diagnostic qui est en train
d'être corrigé puisque nous avons enfin
réussi à intégrer depuis 2020 le
chapitre endométriose dans le programme
de gynéco quelles études de médecine
mais quelle victoire pour ceux qui s'y
intéressent alors vous depuis très
longtemps et on va voir d'ailleurs dans
votre portrait tout de suite que vous
contribuez largement à faire savoir à
faire connaître cette maladie en France
portrait
[Musique]
Isabella chanavaz lâcherait et
gynécologue obstétricienne et médecin de
la reproduction à Bordeaux elle y traite
les formes sévères de l'endométriose dès
2006 elle a organisé des formations pour
les professionnels de santé sur le sujet
elle a participé à l'élaboration de la
stratégie nationale endométriose
présentée par Emmanuel Macron en janvier
[Musique]
docteur chanavaz on a envie de dire que
avant effectivement les femmes qui
avaient mal au ventre une fois par mois
on leur disait ben soufre était toi ça
commence un peu à changer c'est
différent maintenant
mais ça reste quelque chose d'ancrer à
la fois chez les femmes et dans leur
entourage et pour peu qu'une femme et eu
mal au ventre pendant ses règles que sa
fille que sa nièce que sa tante et mal
aussi bah ça banalise et c'est ce qui
fait que quand dans une famille quand il
y a un diagnostic d'endométriose celle
qui a été diagnostiquée va commencer à
aider à diagnostiquer les autres donc ça
ça s'améliore mais ça reste encore
quelque chose de difficile à corriger
quand on interroge une femme sur ces
douleurs de règles elle répond souvent
bah oui comme tout le monde et voilà et
or toutes les femmes n'ont pas des
douleurs de règles en tout cas ne sont
pas égales non endométriose une
définition l'endométriose c'est de
l'endomètre ailleurs que là où il
devrait être c'est-à-dire dans la cavité
utérine l'endomètre d'où endométriose
quel est le processus
il était une maladie qui tordait les
femmes de douleur chaque mois au moment
de leur règle une maladie évoquée
d'Égypte antique perçue comme une
possession démoniaque au Moyen-Âge avant
d'être décrite en 1860 par un médecin
autrichien car le vote qui parlait alors
d'une muqueuse utérine en dehors de
l'utérus
il ne croyait pas si bien dire cette
muqueuse qui tapisse l'intérieur de
l'utérus c'est l'endomètre tous les mois
elle s'épaissit pour accueillir un
embryon mais si aucune grossesse ne
s'installe l'endomètre ne peut pas
rester en place et il doit être évacué
avec les règles l'essentiel s'écoule par
le vagin mais une partie va dans les
trompes et se déverse dans le bas ventre
elle est rapidement nettoyée par le
système immunitaire seulement chez
certaines femmes ce ménage ne se fait
pas bien des cellules de l'endomètre
restent et s'accroches à différents
organes le plus souvent dans les trombes
de Fallope la paroi utérine la vessie
les ovaires ou le côlon
provoquant diverses douleurs
intestinales
urinaires ou lors des rapports sexuels
par exemple malheureusement depuis 1860
les chercheurs n'ont pas encore trouvé
pourquoi chez ses patientes le nettoyage
de l'endomètre se fait mal il reste donc
beaucoup de choses à découvrir afin de
pouvoir vraiment traiter l'endométriose
docteur chanavaz à partir de quel moment
on est diagnostiqué sujet à
l'endométriose alors la maladie peut se
développer dès l'adolescence et ça aussi
c'est quelque chose qui a été méconnu
très longtemps puisque on a considéré
qu'une adolescente qui était torduante
de douleur pendant ses règles c'était
normal c'était normal mais si c'était
normal toutes les filles louer près
l'école tous les mois pendant leur
scolarité c'est pas le cas donc comme
vous disiez tout à l'heure on n'est pas
tout égal face à la douleur et
probablement celle qui sont malades au
point de de ne pas pouvoir aller à
l'école de rester couché d'être obligé
de prendre beaucoup de médicaments ça là
sont extrêmement suspects de développer
une endométriose quels sont les deux
trois symptômes qui vous permettent de
dire à une jeune fille qui vient vous
voir oui c'est l'endométriose alors pour
développer une endométriose il faut
l'association de malfaiteurs le premier
malfaiteur c'est ce défauts de ménage
dans le ventre qui permet aux lésions
d'endométriose de s'installer le
deuxième malfaiteur c'est une réaction
des nerfs de la douleur qui est
exacerbée et qui fait que ces lésions
vont faire mal il y a des femmes des
lésions qui n'ont pas mal et des femmes
qui ont des lésions qui ont mal et donc
il faut l'association des deux c'est
pour ça qu'il existe qu'on appelle des
endométrioses asymptomatiques la lésion
vous la repérer par un examen clinique
alors la chirurgie ils prélèvement et le
diagnostic de certitude aujourd'hui avec
les progrès de l'imagerie on a aussi la
possibilité de poser le diagnostic de
certitude grâce à des images de type
échographie et IRM donc ça c'est
important parce qu'on n'est pas
forcément obligé d'opérer cette maladie
alors qu'auparavant il fallait forcément
l'opérer donc ça c'est une bonne
évolution mais on découvre aussi que des
patientes sur le endométriose dans un
parcours d'infertilité parmi les
patientes infertiles un tiers présentent
de l'endométriose un certain nombre le
savent et un certain nombre de découvre
au moment de la prise en charge de leur
infertilité et parfois ce sont des
endométrioses très sévères qui ont été
sous-estimés ou négligées ou parfois pas
douloureuse et d'ailleurs
sous le chapitre endométriose il y a
quoi il y a les douleurs de règles
premier c'est le premier symptôme et le
plus fréquent en fait l'endométriose je
dis souvent aux c'est la table de 10
le premier disque c'est les
dysménorrhées c'est à dire les douleurs
de règles le deuxième 10 c'est les
disparonies c'est les douleurs de
rapport et le troisième 10 c'est la
dysfertilité c'est à dire la difficulté
obtenir potentiellement une grossesse
après on en a d'autres dyskasi ce sont
les troubles digestifs pendant les
règles
dysuries ce sont les troubles urinaires
mais la douleur elle finit par s'étaler
comme une tâche d'encre et elle peut
ensuite diffuser dans tout l’abdomen
diffuser aux épaules diffusées aux
membres inférieurs quand elle n'est pas
prise en charge elle se chronicise et ça
devient des patientes qui sont
douloureuses tout le temps en fait on
dit que ça provoque aussi des douleurs
au moment des rapports sexuels c'est ce
qu'on appelle la disparonie c'est-à-dire
les douleurs lors des rapports mais ce
sont des douleurs dont les patients
n'ont pas toujours conscience parce que
c'est redoutable mais elles vont adapter
leur sexualité pour éviter ces positions
qui sont qui font mal et pourquoi est-ce
que ces positions se font mal parce que
la verge de leur conjoint touche une
lésion et que dans une autre position
bah ça va pas le faire ça va pas aller
dans la même direction et parfois
la sexualité des couples est très
altérée très modifiée progressivement
sans que forcément ils aient identifié
que que c'était la douleur qui générait
ça tout ça évidemment l'arrière-plan
c'est que ça a été tabou pendant très
très longtemps aujourd'hui vous voyez
beaucoup d'ados qui viennent vous voir
et qui vous disent et un truc qui va pas
ma copine elle a pas mal moi j'ai mal
alors oui moi quand j'ai commencé à
travailler sur l'endométriose il fallait
que j’épèle le mot maintenant c'est bon
je ne l'épelle plus et puis moi j'ai eu
à coeur de former des infirmières
scolaires depuis très longtemps je l'ai
fait dans ma région d'origine je l'ai
fait dans ma région je suis arrivé parce
que les infirmières scolaires sont les
premières à recevoir ces jeunes filles
qui font des malaises pendant les cours
qui vont finir à l'infirmerie et quel
type et qu'elle se dise tiens j'en ai
une ou deux dans cette classe qui sont
vraiment pas bien pendant leurs règles
et celles-là elles sont à risque de
développer une endométriose et grâce aux
associations de patientes et en
particulier en France avec des supports
des livres on arrive à sensibiliser les
ados et avoir plus de diagnostic
maintenant toutes les douleurs quand on
est à dos qui est une période
particulière de la vie ne sont pas
forcément dans il faut aussi prendre le
temps de dire s'en est ou s'en est pas
la maladie est passée un peu de l'ombre
à la lumière néanmoins c'est pas encore
facile de trouver des oreilles
attentives et c'est vrai que dans ces
cas-là il y a beaucoup de femmes qui en
parlent sont les réseaux sociaux et
Marianne Cazaux pour état de santé c'est
pencher justement sur ces femmes qui ont
eu à cœur de populariser de partager
leurs douleurs reportages
Tiphaine Chaillou n'est pas une
influenceuse ordinaire
elle n'affiche pas une vie de rêve et
des voyages au bout du monde mais elle
parle de sa maladie un récit suivi par
près de 14
000 abonnés
pour comprendre pourquoi nous allons
rencontrer Tiphaine Chaillou bonjour
en cher et en os ce journal de
l'endométriose elle a commencé d'abord
pour elle
j'étais tellement seule depuis 10 ans à
chercher des réponses à droite à gauche
avoir des généralistes des médecins de
tous types d'ailleurs et à parler autour
de moi de mes douleurs et j'avais aucune
réponse donc quand j'ai découvert que
c'était une maladie qui touchait des
millions de femmes et que je pouvais
peut-être avoir un lien avec les femmes
et échanger sur des symptômes similaires
au miens je me suis dit je vais partager
cette photo pour montrer ce que je suis
en train de vivre elle reçoit alors des
centaines de messages de soutien et
découvre une communauté bienveillante
prête à l'écouter depuis elle prend un
traitement et a donné naissance à Léane
grâce à la PM mais elle n'a jamais cessé
de raconter son histoire sur sa page ou
sur un podcast qu'elle a créé cela fait
partie désormais de sa thérapie
l'endométriose nous confronte à accepter
une nouvelle réalité une réalité que
nous avons peut-être nier ou ignorer
pendant des années j'ai réalisé que
c'est une crise d'endométriose qui
m'avait fait arrêter le droit même si
c'était pas fait pour moi c'est des
crises d'endométriose qui m'ont fait
renoncer à certaines amitiés je
culpabilisais d'être cette jeune femme
et puis cette femme qui avait vécu tout
ça sans trop savoir pourquoi à cause
d'une douleur fantôme et puis finalement
aujourd'hui je le relie et ça a été
thérapeutique pour moi parce que ça m'a
permis de me réconcilier avec moi-même
et ça c'est quand même un beau cadeau
mais c'est aussi pour aider les autres
femmes que Tiphaine Chaillou tient ce
journal
hello tout le monde j'espère que vous
allez bien aujourd'hui on va parler de
la présence des douleurs malgré les
traitements comme la pilule elle
recommande des livres des recettes ou
des exercices de yoga qui soulagent
et sur les réseaux sociaux elle n'est
pas la seule mais comment faire le tri
dans cette profusion d'information et de
solutions en tout genre
pour aider les patientes les médecins
tentent de se mettre au digital eux
aussi
et l'un d'entre eux pour avoir un
rendez-vous avec ce radiologue
spécialiste de l'endométriose il faut
attendre de longs mois et pour certaines
venir de loin
pour l'instant la prise en charge n'est
pas du tout assez optimal
puisqu'il y a encore une grande errance
diagnostique et que les patientes sont
abandonnées pour la plupart encore à
leur sort
très fréquemment effectivement donc
c'est relatif aveu d'échec il a donc
accepté de contribuer au projet de l'une
de ses patientes Hélène entier elle a
créé une plateforme en ligne pour mieux
accompagner les femmes qui se sentent
démunis
les retours que j'ai eu sur la Vendôme
sont favorables parce que j'ai eu
plusieurs patients qui m'ont déjà parlé
c'est un complément tout à fait efficace
et qui complète parce que tu sais très
bien que les consultations sont toujours
trop brèves finalement à leur goût elles
sont très désireuses d'être actrice de
leur maladie
parce que c'est 50% du traitement c'est
elle
la gestion de leur mode de vie
l'amélioration de l'hygiène au sens
large du terme quand on apprend qu'on a
justement cette maladie en fait c'est
pas la fin de l'errance c'est le début
d'une nouvelle souvent pour nous toutes
donc on a besoin de savoir un petit peu
où aller et d'ailleurs si tu veux que je
te montre tu vois par exemple l'article
sur la fatigue et l'endométriose a
énormément marché pareil ce qu'on fait
avec Mélanie cordon en sexo et endo des
sujets hyper tabous dont on n'arrive pas
forcément à parler avec son spécialiste
la plateforme offre des articles de
décryptage et une option payante avec
des exercices et des groupes de soutien
tous en sont convaincus les patientes
doivent être actrices de leur traitement
elles devront vivre avec la maladie
pendant une grande partie de leur vie
en attendant une meilleure prise en
charge
comme pour toutes les maladies on va sur
Internet d'abord pour prendre des
renseignements sur ces douleurs donc sur
l'endométriose il y a du bon on voit
bien que ça serre les femmes quand même
les réseaux sociaux il y a du mauvais
alors je pense que on peut pas annoncer
endométriose à une jeune femme sont tout
de suite tout lui expliquer parce qu'il
y a de tout du bon et du moins bon sur
les réseaux sociaux des informations et
surtout malheureusement quand on dit
endométriose les patients entendent
stérilité ce qui n'est absolument pas la
loi dans l'endométriose donc oui il faut
prendre le temps d'expliquer la maladie
il faut prendre le temps d'expliquer que
la majorité des femmes qui ont de
l'endométriose n'auront aucun problème
pour avoir des enfants
mais que ça et que c'est une maladie qui
avec laquelle il faut apprendre à vivre
et qu'on peut très bien vivre avec une
endométriose à condition d'être
diagnostiquée et pris en charge donc
quand on vient vous voir vous nous
donnez quel traitement est-ce qu'il y en
a on ne sait pas guérir de cette maladie
parce qu'on ne sait pas pourquoi ces
femmes ne font pas correctement le
ménage dans leur ventre et on c'est pas
leur apprendre à le faire on s'est
soigné pour l'instant c'est lors de la
recherche on cherche on cherche à
comprendre ce défaut de ménage mais on
n'a pas on a des clés mais pas toutes
les clés qui expliquent tous les défauts
de ménage en fait par contre on sait la
soigner et le principe du soin c'est que
comme elles font pas bien le ménage dans
leur ventre autant que ça reste propre
et pour que ça reste propre bah autant
qu'il y ait pas de règle qui se découle
dans le ventre et autant ne pas avoir de
règles ah oui donc c'est en fait on
soulage en coupant
soigne mais non ne traite pas et
effectivement aujourd'hui
quelque chose qui supprime les règles il
y a peut-être des réticences à ce
soulagement à ce traitement parce que
enchaîné les pilules les femmes sont
quand même très imprégnées par les
risques propres à la pilule alors il y a
beaucoup d'idées préconçues qui sont
qu'il faut
détricoter en consultation il y a aussi
des femmes qui ne la tolèrent pas
malheureusement moi je leur dis vous
avez pas de bol vous avez la double
peine c'est que vous avez le
l'endométrie vous allez vous tolérer pas
bien les Horm néanmoins en l'espace de
quelques années il y a une
multiplication de différentes pilules et
il y a pas une bonne pilule dans
l'endométriose il y a la bonne pilule
pour chaque femme et la bonne pilule
c'est pas de saignement pas d'effets
secondaires arriver à ce combo parfois
c'est facile parfois c'est compliqué et
parfois on y arrive pas donc il peut y
avoir de longues tentatives jusqu'à
trouver la bonne molécule il faut pas
décourager vous êtes là pour ça pour les
pour les réconforter alors vous nous
disiez docteur il n'y a pas de
traitement curatifs on n'a pas trouvé la
recherche cherche mais tu as pas encore
trouvé Marianne Cazeau c'est penché sur
le niveau de recherche en France sur
l'endométriose reportage
une femme sur dix souffre d'endométriose
pourtant il n'existe aucun traitement
ciblé contre la maladie un constat qui
repose en partie sur une injustice
comme en témoigne les dépenses du
principal institut de financement de la
recherche aux États-Unis pour des
maladies telles que le diabète ou
l'asthme qui touche autant de femmes que
l'endométriose le budget du net était de
1 milliard de dollars pour le diabète et
de 34 millions de dollars pour l'asthme
et il était seulement de 7 millions de
dollars pour l'endométriose il y a eu
moins d'intérêt sur la santé des femmes
avec aussi un peu une banalisation des
douleurs donc les choses sont en train
de changer mais
ce gros écart là représente cette
histoire là c'est le cheval de bataille
de Marina klascoff depuis 17 ans cette
épidémiologiste épluche les données
médicales disponibles à la recherche
d'indices sur les causes de
l'endométriose à
peu d'équipe s'intéressaient à la
question j'ai commencé à lire sur cette
maladie et je me suis dit mais j'en ai
jamais entendu parler et on connaît rien
moi je lisais les articles scientifiques
en abymologie et je
enfin voilà moi je travaillais sur le
cancer donc j'avais l'habitude qu'on
connaisse beaucoup de choses et là on
connaissait rien donc je me suis dit
mais j'ai envie de travailler sur cette
maladie j'ai envie en fait je suis
curieuse de savoir qu'est-ce qu'il a
cause et j'ai aussi envie de pouvoir
faire quelque chose pour ces millions de
femmes touchées consult on a les cycles
pour le moment son enquête n'a permis
d'identifier que cinq facteurs de risque
établis de la maladie de nombreux autres
pistes sont en cours d'investigation
mais la plupart des études comportent
des biais elle considère la maladie
comme une entité homogène ce qui ne
facilite pas les recherches
[Musique]
pour éviter cet écueil Marina peut
compter sur une autre chercheuse engagée
à l'Institut Cochin Carole Abbot se
concentre sur les formes héréditaires de
l'endométriose elle a inclu dans son
étude différents membres de la famille
de patients
par exemple pour cette famille là donc
on voit les deux parents avec 4 soeurs
et parmi ces quatre soeurs de sont
atteintes d'endométriose le nombre de
femmes suivies est restreint mais cela
permet de bien caractériser chacune des
formes dont elle souffre s'il s'agit
d'une atteinte ovarienne ou bien d'une
atteinte profonde avec un module
digestif c'est pas forcément la même
maladie sur le plan clinique mais
également sur le plan génétique et donc
au sein de de cette étude là l'idée
était d'avoir des cas extrêmement bien
précisé pour pouvoir comparer ce qui est
comparable et avoir toutes les
informations précises sur chaque cas
avec son équipe Carole labo a prélevé
des échantillons d’adn sur chacun des
membres de la famille elle espère ainsi
identifier des mutations génétiques qui
pourraient expliquer la survenue de la
maladie les résultats trouvés sur ces
cas particuliers pourront être par la
suite vérifier sur une mélange plus
large de patiente
chacun apporte son petit grain de sable
et petit à petit en améliorant les
connaissances sur la physiopathologie de
la maladie on arrive à un moment donné à
pouvoir proposer une avancée
thérapeutique en comprenant mieux les
mécanismes en cause dans la maladie
cela prendra du temps mais les
chercheuses ne sont pas près de baisser
les bras d'autant plus que les choses
bougent grâce à une enveloppe de 30
millions d'euros promises par le
gouvernement pour la recherche sur la
santé des femmes la chercheuse va mettre
au point la plus grande base de données
au monde sur la maladie
les scientifiques ont bon espoir de
trouver la réponse au mystère des causes
de l'endométriose
docteur on a consacré une émission
d'état de santé il y a quelques temps
sur le fait que lorsqu'il s'agissait de
pathologies féminines la recherche était
beaucoup moins allante il y avait
beaucoup de retards par rapport à des
pathologies qui sont principalement qui
touchent principalement les hommes
est-ce que vous diriez que dans le cadre
de l'endométriose le retard pris dans la
recherche est aussi lié à une forme de
de sous-estimation de la maladie alors
comme je vous le disais tout à l'heure
c'est une maladie qui n'a pas été
enseignée au profil de santé pendant des
années donc il y a une prise de
conscience
c'est une maladie qui prend plein
d'aspects différents qu'on peut
diagnostiquer de plein de manières et on
a parfois du mal à comprendre pourquoi
des femmes qui ont des lésions très
sévères ne se plaignent pas alors que
d'autres lésions très modérée se
plaignent donc c'est ce qui fait que
c'est compliqué de faire de la recherche
il y a des projets de recherche il y en
a plein quand vous cherchez la
littérature scientifique selon la
maîtrise on voit beaucoup de choses mais
ça part un peu dans tous les sens et
souvent on a du mal à pérenniser
financièrement des projets de recherche
qui ont commencé à trouver des choses et
qu'il faut aller plus loin et c'est ça
qui est difficile alors on se pose
toujours la question dans cette émission
de savoir comment une pathologie est
prise en charge plus ou moins bien par
la puissance publique vous avez voulu
poser la question à un député en
l'occurrence Stéphane Viry député LR sur
la possibilité que la sécurité sociale
prenne en charge les soins
on écoute sa réponse et on en parle
juste après
la volonté en tout cas pour ma part
c'était déjà de faire en sorte que la
France se saisisse de cette question de
cette maladie pour que globalement la
réponse qui puisse être apportée soit
uniforme et j'espère la meilleure la
meilleure ça nous paraissait peut-être
avec un certain nombre de collègues de
faire reconnaître l'endométriose comme
étant une affection longue durée puisque
la classification en ALD permet aux
patients de bénéficier d'une prise en
charge de certains traitements de
certains accompagnements par l'Assurance
Maladie ce que le droit commun ne permet
pas voilà les raisons pour lesquelles
nous souhaitions faire progresser cette
cause de la Ld l'Assemblée nationale a
délibérée à l'unanimité pour inviter le
gouvernement à réagir après le sujet est
à la main du gouvernement qui doit
prendre des initiatives selon son
pouvoir qui est le sien pour faire
avancer la question
force est de constater que pour le
moment on voit rien arriver et qu'il
faudra probablement que les députés ils
apprennent reprennent les initiative
pour tenter de faire bouger les lignes
comme on souhaite le faire
quoi il vous semble important de plaider
pour une prise en charge par la sécurité
sociale des des frais liés à
l'endométriose cette reconnaissance en
affection longue durée permet que la
sécurité sociale rembourse à 100%, ce
qui est déjà pris en charge à 65 %. le
restant le reste à charge en fait or
dans l'anométriose
une grande partie des traitements
médicaux hormonaux sont pris et son soit
remboursés soit pas très cher et déjà
remboursé par les mutuelles et là LD la
section longue durée ne remboursera pas
les pilules non remboursées et être
accompagnés par un sexologue un
psychologue un psychosexologue ben tout
ça c'est pas pris en charge être capable
d'appréhender sa douleur et de la gérer
et d'apprendre à faire de la sophrologie
pour la gestion de sa douleur mais ça
s'est pas pris en charge et donc ce sont
tous ces soins de support qui coûte qui
grèvent le budget des patients
endométriose qui cherchent chacune de
leurs côtés et qui aurait besoin d'être
aidé donc il y a certaines mutuelles qui
vont prendre en charge une ou deux ou
trois séances de d'ostéopathie par
exemple qui peuvent faire énormément de
bien mais pas plus et tout ça ça n'est
pas pris en charge pour finir
l'endométriose en France est pris au
sérieux ou pas il y a 15 ans vraiment il
y avait des histoires à pleurer où il
était évident qu'une femme avait des
symptômes sévères depuis des années et
que elle était elle avait errée de
médecins au médecin elle avait dit sa
souffrance et que on était passé à côté
et nous on l'a récupéré avec des formes
une forme extrêmement sévère en
regrettant de pas l'avoir connu 10 ans
plus tôt je crois que c'est moins le cas
en tout cas c'est l'impression que j'en
ai
peut-être même il y a une ultra
vigilance surtout des mamans qui
elle-même endométriose et qui sont
terrorisés quand elles voient leur ados
comment savoir mal au ventre pendant les
règles parce qu'elles n'ont pas du tout
envie qu'elle revu la même chose j'ai
l'impression clairement que les choses
s'améliorent oui maintenant est-ce que
c'est suffisant c'est difficile à dire
non mais c'est pas mal de voir le verre
à moitié plein déjà vous qui êtes
immergé dans cette maladie encore une
fois pour laquelle vous faites beaucoup
merci d'avoir été avec nous dans cet
état de santé merci de nous avoir suivis
à très vite sur LCP
[Musique]
elle s'est fait Assemblée nationale en
partenariat avec mgeen mutuelle santé
prévoyance vous a présenté état de santé
[Musique]